- Thanks for hanging out
with me so much
since Matt was seduced by
the siren's call
of a mediocre street artist.
- No problem, but also
I don't really have a choice.
You keep showing up
wherever I am
and talking to me
about how you're mad.
- Yeah, I feel like
our friendship's
really blossoming too.
- And that's when I told
Lady Gaga,
"No, you text me."
[all laugh]
She texted me.
She did.
- I've had enough.
The infatuation with this guy
is unreasonable.
Nobody is that interesting.
I'm gonna say something.
- Don't do it.
You don't have the social clout
to face him.
Jake!
- I see how it works.
We all work side by side
for years,
then some fraud
in a loser mask shows up,
and suddenly
he's everyone's best friend.
Greg, I'd expect this from you.
But Fred, Laura?
I thought our friendship
meant something.
- Those aren't
any of their names.
- Face it,
you're just a rip-off artist,
and you probably wear that mask
'cause you have an ugly face.
[solemn piano music]
- Actually, Jake,
I wear the mask,
because when I was 22,
a child molester pushed my face
into a campfire.
Nothing the doctors did could
ever make my face a face again.
♪ ♪
Is that you wanted to hear?
[sobbing]
- Wow.
- Jake,
I think you should leave.
- Fine.
Come on, Grace,
we're not wanted here.
- Right behind you, Jake.
- You are so brave.
- I know, right?
[chuckles]